canadienne ne peuvent plus payer mais le
gouverne le chiffre conservateur est
connu pour sa maîtrise des réseaux
sociaux et ses vidéos incisives
se retourne sous des noms contre lui
le réseau global a révélé que depuis 4
ans ses vidéos sur la plateforme Youtube
sont associés à un mot-clic controversé
men going qu'on pourrait traduire par
les hommes qui suivent leur propre
chemin un mouvement anti-féministe et
misogyne
c'est une sorte d'idéologie ou mouvance
internet
pas mal extrême associé au mouvement
masculiniste donc la croyance centrale
c'est que les femmes détruisent la
société le mot clic qu'on appelle une
balise intégrée n'est pas visible aux
internautes HTML site web de YouTube
mais se trouve dans le code de
programmation l'effet que cette vidéo-là
va être sensiblement mieux référencer
auprès des gens qui effectuent des
recherches à propos de ce mouvement-là
depuis le mot clic a disparu des vidéos
mais je lui dis après-midi il était
encore associé à la chaîne Youtube de
Pierre poillievre on voit ici
mgto
Mengong l'affaire a vite déclenché une
tempête commune
ont carrément été inversés à la période
des questions pierre poillievre a été
forcée de s'expliquer
le mouvement et assurer avoir corrigé le
problème quand il a appris son existence
son équipe affirme qu'il n'était pas au
courant ces adversaires n'en croient
rien et passe à l'attaque
a choisi
d'aller chercher des groupes anti femmes
misogènes
extrémiste de droite pour avancer son
agenda politique
délibérée d'aller chercher des créneaux
d'appui
c'est choquant et dangereux 17 ministres
libérales
les députés conservateurs ne faisaient
pas de détour pour défendre leur chef
celui-ci parle de foutaises
les plus récents sondages démontrent que
Pierre poillievre est plus populaire
chez les hommes que chez les femmes
cette controverse n'a rien pour aider à
renverser cette tendance ici Louis
Blouin Radio-Canada